my name is Xavier Maassen son I am an
Argentinean sociology's Argentina
defaulted 95 billion dollars on its step
in 2001 between 2005 the government of
the now this is Nestor Kirchner
managed to agree with the debtors to pay
with a reduction of 70% but there was a
7% the holdouts led today by Paul singer
from nml who did not agree with the
offer and wanted to get paid in full
what is sewing are here today to 1.3
billion dollars from New York Tomas visa
ruled in favor of these groups these
laws are referred to as witness in
Argentina that means vultures and they
get this name because they are not the
original creditors but groups that
bought the debt for pennies and then try
to collect them in full today Argentina
is afraid that if he pays the vultures
for what they ask
then rest of the debtors are going to
seek equal treatment and that is going
to be a big problem because it's only
one point three billion dollars which is
not a very big deal but if it's get paid
then all these other folks can ensure
technically speaking Argentinians only
imminency on the phone it is and is
going to be hopefully much different
from the one that Cynthia suffer in 2001
that is to say there will be no run on
the banks no gore Alito's but of course
any type of default will definitely not
have a good impact in and already
depressed and problematic Argentine
economy